yeah welcome to this video playing a
chess game and this is maku hawked ich
einen yeah so what do we get here an
interesting thing here 93 this is an
opening with many names um what is this
actually h5 can I already let's let's go
let's go with that g 6 h-4 that that
could be quite interesting I'm getting
this h5 back and this is summer tech in
light c3 is a funny opening it has many
names it's actually not having a clear
name it's sometimes called the front
gate opening named by named after dutch
player sometimes called the slight nur
the Dunst opening I think yeah and in
German chess circles also sometimes
called the links ringer the night on the
left after a book that was released a
couple of years ago by a German feeder
master Chi lock and it's actually an
interesting book I'm i think i have that
book actually maybe I gave it to someone
yeah Knight c3 interesting Knight c3 g6
now let's take here on edge fire doesn't
that seems quite right and f7 yeah it's
a back to basics
maybe it's a bit irritated then I played
this kind of stuff but it's the offbeat
week what can I do yeah what is black
supposed to play here it's not so not so
straightforward so I'm going for 95 here
if he allows it
thank you it is definitely some
compensation maybe not the kind of
compensation that is good enough for a
grandmaster game and tournament chess
but it's certainly good enough for blitz
maybe something like a six and then
Queenie seven if I go 95 not sure that I
will do that mmm that looks a bit
artificial threatening 96 as well left
before here right before or they have
something better that that that looks
really shaky here even light b5 as a
move but before I before Queen to e5 mmm
25 maybe
now before Queenie five isn't that clear
actually it isn't that clear what is
Bishop b2 actually I'm threatening than
night and threatening 96 then what is he
playing again said my queen is protected
maybe this is rather clever he cannot
move his bishop and he can Knight to
King d7 is not possible 96 queen age 59
evade with a good end game yeah that's
actually quite nice let's play that
that's actually nice 96 is now a very
serious threat what is his smooth Night
Moves don't help bishop moves don't help
King the 896 loses the queen and king d
796 queen 85 90 x fa to check okay that
is a move maybe but i have g for now d
for he has to move the Queen again to f6
probably is there something better maybe
but it is it is pretty good right on or
what about bishop no Bishop g4 is not on
its f4 better maybe f4 Queen f6 no
probably not let's go d for Queen have
six and now TT 5 no probably not d five
chicks might be 5 9 a-6
you will put the Queen on g6 soon that's
a bit annoying t five chicks takes not
not really huh
okay let's play for strategic
compensation in a way not rushing things
I think age six probably he has to do
something against f5 f5 is pretty pretty
big threat so h6 I guess
interesting h6 I can't even take e6
maybe that's the right way let's do that
that doesn't lose time it's not what I
intended originally but maybe it's the
right f5 and what is he doing next Queen
f6 I'm out for a 5v5 TX 94 e 5 cakes 94
is strong and Queen g7 and now just
taking it on it's a bit difficult for
him to move maybe just this for
cancelling long as I can we can actually
go for long castles now I should have
played at least f6 at least f6 time
morning okay
no choice let's hear in for a penny in
for a penny in for a pound or what is
this called giving away the jaw here 46
but maybe no castle this is doing the
job
where I definitely had good chances but
that's not the way to play it wasn't
right yeah I know he gets gets his
bloody King out of it what a shame that
was such a great position seat was
hanging unfortunately now that position
is super shaky anyway to to irritate him
even it's very difficult
check this is this is winning rook t3 is
made gt3 is made occasion nice
preferring this okay now that was set
for Cyrus to preside very stupid and it
was completely busted now this is just a
winning position for wine i'm pretty
sure about that just so strong White's
initiative but where it where is it
where can I win this for real Bishop g4
hmm ok it's not as good as I thought I
just thought that this should be just
winning four wide but it's not so clear
therefore h6 Bishop g4 is is the way to
go but it's not a win that's just just
good let's say queen here and now this
for bishop CA it interesting yeah rights
initiative s is very strong quite
clearly you know he has to play this
move actually to play king c7 and then
cover this this thing down c8 this is
the the engine oops the engines line
it's quite quite strange weather with an
advantage for white slide one huh we add
stuff yeah maybe I had something better
even I have absolutely zero belief and
this Knight a5 business and Queenie five
let's see maybe maybe even know
something better than we should be
toward before it's not not doing the
deal 25 vs okay there should be two
Queenie 5d for here yeah f4 looks so
normal yeah this probably is right age
69 is a special g4 move that gives
compensation and yet it doesn't seem
that that is that's not enough but you
have to play here to play of sexy IM
I really really played it played in
badly I have to go f6 this is the only
way to kind of continue this stuff and
then Castle go for long castles it's not
not a clear position the engine gives
black a slight advantage probably four
maybe five is just a bit too much i mean
i can't play like this maybe this is
what I should have done just play for a
strategic compensation like this and
then G for some white space is pretty
pretty substantial computer gives equal
and I mean whole exchange down yeah but
that's that that was just not working at
all but here it's very difficult and for
hangs I have no move release so I
thought okay what the heck just give him
that but 96 long castle saves very
easily actually okay well thanks for
watching